flooding america that's the focus of
tonight's angle
the american people have been voting
since 2008 for presidents to stop the
never-ending wars in the middle east
but little did anyone know that under
biden that wouldn't just mean bringing
our troops home from afghanistan it
would mean bringing afghanistan here
according to axios the bide
administration yesterday informed
governors and mayors in 46 states to get
ready to welcome the first group of
about 37 000 afghan refugees nearly 5
300 for california 4 500 for texas
nearly 2 000 for washington and so on
and by the way that number is just for
starters in a recent budget request the
biden administration asked congress for
funds to resettle a total of i hope
you're sitting a hundred and sixty
thousand refugees through september of
2022.
we're going to be looking for support
from from all of you on this and
particularly a few things uh for afghans
who are paroled uh into the united
states to receive the same benefits that
refugees do there are some significant
funds uh that will be requested so uh
that is coming uh and in fact we need to
uh get this done quickly
oh no we don't
support like this is a telethon now if
that happens by the way the number of
afghan immigrants living in the u.s
would more than double
from where that number was before the
airlifts during that chaotic withdrawal
we've kind of gone from we need to get
the translators and interpreters out to
we need to bring everyone who wants to
come from afghanistan here to the united
states stat
well as the new york times recently
reported the planes were often filled
haphazardly with unaccompanied minors
separated from parents
others without passports or papers
mothers with large families who just
wanted to get out of afghanistan
and fighting age men
many of the afghans we airlifted out did
not qualify for the special immigrant
visa program
tens of thousands were therefore what's
called paroled into the u.s on a
humanitarian basis
but do not worry kids
because the same guy who was doing those
back channels with china before trump
left office and who thought that the
afghan army would totally stand and
fight once we were gone
he assures us that the vetting of these
people is a-okay relax
because they're cross-referencing terror
watchlists
excuse me if i'm unimpressed about that
all right let's not kid ourselves
these checks mean next to nothing our
system is not set up to do thousands of
them a day
in fact the washington times reported
today that customs officials arrested an
afghan refugee
who was convicted for aggravated robbery
in 2011 and deported
in 2017. yet somehow
clever man he made it through the ever
vigilant team of biden's security net
guys
and before that an afghan man who was
deported after being convicted of rape
got all the way to dulles airport
but he was at least caught and arrested
but how many got through
trump used common sense measures to do
things like control the border and in
doing so he saved lives money and
american jobs
but biden came in and he just blew it
all up
and by the way they knew exactly what
would follow
like we're seeing in afghanistan a mass
of humanity coming to the united states
because for them neither of these things
is a crisis
they're opportunities
an opportunity to fundamentally
transform the country grow dependency on
government programs and build a new
constituency
and as the tragedy unfolds
we're not supposed to raise any
questions oh no not about the migrants
or the refugees
we're supposed to smile and put up one
of those hate has no home here annoying
yard signs
we're issuing a call to action to other
companies and organizations that want to
help afghans starting new lives in the
united states
we will help you find a way to make an
impact we have to recognize that we have
a big moral debt to a much larger number
of afghans we should at least have a
much larger refugee program accepting
afghan refugees and the willingness to
accept more because we have to do more
what
have you ever seen any of them as
insistent about how we have to do more
about helping our homeless vets there
are about 60 000 of them living on the
street every night in the united states
not for one millisecond do they ever
consider the burden that they're putting
on hard-working americans nor do they
care
the costs are massive
the center for immigration studies
crunched the numbers and they found that
u.s households headed by an afghan
immigrant are twice as likely to live in
or near poverty as those headed by a
native born american
likewise 65 percent of afghan-headed
households used at least one major
welfare program in 2019
that's 2.5 times the rate of households
headed by a native-born american
now
america guys we all know this is already
in the hole for the two trillion dollars
it's spent on the war effort in
afghanistan and iraq
but now we're on the hook for an
additional 64 million dollars in aid and
then billions more in money and it over
decades in various social services
we're talking housing stipends
food stamps
health care
job training
esl classes
and of course public schooling
now we all know schools are already
struggling with covet mandates and now
they're going to have to find i guess
pashtun speakers to teach these kids
even republicans
from conservative states
they somehow fall into the trap
they're wonderful they've supported our
men and women in uniform they love
america they are hard workers we would
love to welcome them into the state we
have a moral responsibility those are
people to whom we owe a debt of
gratitude and we would welcome them into
our country
now they can all live in one of your
houses man
now where's the pushback to this
insanity as usual most in the gop are
mia according to axios not one state
official declined to take in afghans
but here's my question
do any of them really have a choice
because the americans living in those
states sure as hell didn't get one
virtue signaling politicians and
activists say we must take as many of
the quote at-risk afghans as we can
because quote we made them a promise
first of all who made what promise
was a law passed by congress stipulating
that if the afghans couldn't hold off
the taliban
we'd take them all in
or anyone who could make it over the
fence and into a plane i i didn't see
that anywhere
meanwhile europe for its part is saying
no thank you we're full
french president emmanuel macron said
france needs to protect itself from a
wave of migrants
austria's interior minister remarked
there is no reason why an afghan should
now come to austria
croatian president zoran milanovic
declared all of them should find their
place in the united states thanks zoran
but of course if you question the
process if you question the numbers or
the cost well you're a bigot
you've got these crazy people on the
right um doing you know what they what
they always do uh with their
fear-mongering and their hateful
rhetoric i know what some of these
people are uh worried about is that
they're worried that refugees like
myself when they come to this country
will outshine them
oh yeah we can't sleep at night because
of that
well that's an evil lie against the
american people who are some of the most
generous people on earth
we have no hostility toward the refugees
themselves
our anger is toward a selfish leader
selfish leadership
and the entire leadership class that can
never get enough of cheap workers can
never do enough to lower wages for
hard-working americans that pays no
attention to our laws or cares about the
good people who happen to actually live
here and who welcomed elon omar into the
country by the way
biden and his team don't care about
these refugees
they just see them as fodder for cheap
labor and easy votes
that's why we're angry and that's why we
won't tolerate high-handed lectures from
fear mongers like congresswoman omar
we've seen this movie before
the democrats bust open our borders for
their political benefit the republicans
let them do it for cheap labor
and then the outlier busts in to set
things right
the sequel could be coming in 2024 and
that's the angle